-Today, a federal
communications commission
voted to repeal the Obama-era
net neutrality rules.
Meanwhile,
the Trump White House
was once again
consumed by petty dramas.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]
Today, the Republican-led FCC
voted to dismantle
the free and open Internet
by repealing
former President Obama's
net neutrality rules,
which were designed to ensure
that all web traffic
is treated equally
and prevents service providers
from blocking
or filtering content
they don't want you to see.
The FCC is led by Ajit Pai,
who is best known
for both his opposition
to net neutrality
and for the size
of his coffee mug.
-Greetings, Chairman Pai.
Mindy Hill with TheDCVoice.com.
-Hi.
-And I just have a comment.
During the Obama administration,
the FCC had no jurisdiction...
[ Laughter ]
...over regulating programming.
-I'm sorry, but you can't just
drink from a mug that size
without any explanation.
[ Laughter ]
Was the mug always that big,
or did you shrink?
Are you sharing an office
with Rick Moranis?
[ Laughter ]
Is that why you want
to limit the Internet,
so people can't go online
and make memes about you
and your giant coffee mug?
[ Laughter ]
Now, polls show
that Americans overwhelmingly
support net neutrality,
with 83% overall in favor
of keeping the FCC rules,
including 75% of Republicans,
and it makes sense Republicans
would favor an open Internet.
Otherwise, they'd have
to get their news
from newspapers or CNN
instead of Facebook group
PatriotEagleMAGA1776.
[ Laughter ]
Net neutrality ensures an open
and democratic Internet,
where people can make
and access content equally.
But Pai has argued that limiting
regulation of the Internet
would actually encourage
companies to innovate more,
and he keeps using
one phrase in particular.
-Until 2015,
we had light-touch regulation.
The consumer is best served
with light-touch regulation.
It's under
that light-touch framework --
Light-touch regulation --
And that's the kind of success
that we want to promote
in the future,
with light-touch regulation.
-Please stop using the term
"light touch."
You sound like someone
defending themselves to HR.
[ Laughter ]
"What did Deborah say I did?
That was a light touch!"
[ Laughter and applause ]
You were there!
It was light!"
And yet despite the potentially
disastrous consequences
of this vote, D.C. and the Trump
White House in particular
have been consumed once again
by chaos and drama,
like, for example the firing
of longtime Trump ally Omarosa.
Now, Omarosa's
official job title
was Communications Director for
the Office of Public Liaison,
but no one was ever really sure
exactly what she did
in the White House.
In fact, before she was fired,
all anyone had ever heard
about Omarosa's time
in the White House
was that she held a photo shoot
with her bridesmaids
there in April
before getting married.
Politico reported
that Omarosa brought members
of her 39-person bridal party
to 1600 Pennsylvania Avenue
for an extended
wedding photo shoot,
catching fellow senior aides
and some security officials
by surprise
in her bridal attire.
The visitors
loudly wandered around,
looking to snap photos
in the Rose Garden
and throughout the West Wing.
Oh, my God. Trump's staff
treats the White House
the way tourists
treat the M&M Store.
[ Laughter ]
"I want a picture
with the green one!"
[ Laughter ]
Also, 39 bridesmaids?
Is it a massive wedding,
or are you just trying to make
one friend feel really terrible?
"I'm sorry, Becky,
the max was 39,
and you're my 40th best friend."
[ Laughter ]
Now, apparently,
it was Chief of Staff John Kelly
who did the firing,
although Trump signed off on it,
reporting that
was confirmed by April Ryan,
White House correspondent of
American Urban Radio Networks,
in one especially great moment
when Ryan called back
to Trump's famous catchphrase.
-So, General Kelly had
had enough,
and he'd finally gotten
the President to sign off.
And last night,
it did not end well.
-She was a contestant
on "The Apprentice,"
President Trump's
former TV program,
so they have a history.
They go way back.
-And she was fired again.
-Twice, yeah.
-All right.
I don't know if he said,
"You're fired."
-He didn't say, "You're fired,"
but General Kelly said,
"You're fired."
-All right.
Everybody stand by.
There's more news.
-Damn, look at her sipping from
her mug while she says that.
The only way
that would've been better,
if she had Ajit Pai's mug.
[ Laughter ]
Today on "Good Morning America,"
Omarosa claimed
that the stories about her exit
from the White House
were not true.
Specifically,
she refuted reports that
she blew up at Kelly
and had to be escorted
off the White House premises.
In fact, Omarosa said
that she didn't make a scene
and that Kelly fired her
in a very private place.
-I resigned, and I didn't
do that in the residence,
as being reported.
John Kelly and I sat down
in the Situation Room,
which is a very secure, very
quiet room in the White House.
-Wow, the Situation Room.
Though I have a feeling
any room Omarosa goes into
becomes a Situation Room.
[ Laughter ]
Seriously, you know it's bad
when they have to fire you
in the same place
they killed Osama Bin Laden.
[ Laughter ]
Omarosa --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Omarosa also claimed
she had a story to tell
and would eventually
tell that story
once her tenure
at the White House
is officially over.
And later,
when the "GMA" anchors
were discussing the interview,
Robin Roberts gave her
the perfect sendoff.
-She said
she has a story to tell,
and I'm sure
she'll be selling that story.
-We'll see.
-Yeah, she will.
Bye, Felicia.
-Damn.
[ Laughter and applause ]
D-a-a-amn!
I wish all news anchors
signed off that way.
That's how Edward R. Murrow
should've signed off
during the McCarthy era.
"Good night, good luck,
and bye, Felicia."
[ Laughter ]
Now, of course, it's never fun
to relish anyone's firing,
but Omarosa routinely attacked
Trump's critics
and even went so far as to
threaten people who crossed him.
And while Robin Roberts
might have been ice-cold,
others were less muted in their
reactions to Omarosa's firing,
like CNN commentator Angela Rye.
-Brooke, I'm gonna do
what you can't do
and what April and Symone
are too good of people to do,
and that's just
gonna be petty for a minute.
Ahh-ha-ha-ha-ha!
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, Angela.
Oh, Angela.
-Bye, girl!
Bye!
Goodbye, good riddance, goodbye.
Deuces. Out.
-Angela, you know
I have much love for you,
but you know what?
I don't delight
in anyone's demise.
-I'm not delighting
in her demise.
I wish her the best,
but ahh-ha-ha!
[ Laughter and applause ]
-I'm not sure you can really
say, "I wish her the best"...
[ Laughter ]
...when it's followed by this.
-Ahh!
[ Laughter ]
-When she did that, I'm pretty
sure the closed captioning said,
"I wish her the best -- psych!"
[ Laughter ]
But, of course,
Omarosa is not the only
longtime Trump acolyte
who's suddenly on the outs.
There's also former White House
Chief Strategist Steve Bannon,
an early and vocal backer
of Roy Moore in Alabama.
Bannon went to war
with the GOP establishment
and managed to lose
a Senate seat in arguably
the most Republican state
in the country,
and that has led to many
Republicans turning on him,
like New York Republican
Congressman Peter King,
who did not hold back in an
interview on CNN on Wednesday.
-Why Bannon?
Why is he such a big deal?
-I was even ready -- not even so
much as a political issue.
Almost as a moral issue.
This guy does not belong
on the national stage.
He looks like some
disheveled drunk
that wandered onto
the political stage.
-Hey, Peter King,
you doing my job now?
[ Laughter ]
I'll do the "looks like" jokes
around here.
Steve Bannon looks like a cop
who went undercover
to solve a case,
and then they forgot to tell him
the case was solved,
so he just stayed undercover
for another 10 years.
[ Laughter and applause ]
"I got a lead!"
So, Republicans on the FCC
are trying to dismantle
the free and open Internet,
despite overwhelming opposition,
and the Trump White House
is consumed once again
by petty drama.
I don't know how long it'll be
before Republicans
are kicked out of office,
but when it happens,
I hope it's reported like this.
-Bye, Felicia.
-This has been "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]